a new year a new PM a new set of
promises to a country he knows is
running out of patience people don't
want politicians who promise the Earth
and then fail to deliver
they want government to focus Less on
politics and more on the things they
care about the cost of living too high
waiting times in the NHS too long
illegal migration
far too much Britain's grappling with
soaring inflation the worst strikes in
decades and an NHS in crisis and this a
prime minister trying to offer a plan
five promises
we will halve inflation grow the economy
reduce debt cut waiting lists and stop
the boats those are the people's
priorities they are your government's
priorities and we will either have
achieved them or not no tricks no
ambiguity but light on answers for the
immediate pressures on the NHS when it
comes to Emergency Care the most
impressing priority we have is is to
move people into social care with the
communities that will mean that we can
actually get ambulances flowing and no
solution to the standoff with nurses
overpay I don't think anyone thinks that
a 19 pay rise is Affordable but that
doesn't mean we shouldn't have dialogue
that we shouldn't have conversations but
number 10 clear those conversations will
not be about reopening last year's pay
deal with nurses day-to-day difficulties
still far from being fixed in the real
world you can't get a train you can't
get a doctor's appointment that's the
reality of Britain in 2020 23 and now
you're here giving people more promises
about how you might change the country
that they've heard many times before
during 13 years of conservative rule my
question really is why should the public
believe you're any different to any of
your predecessors well Beth I think the
country have seen me performing the job
before through really difficult times
they saw me as Chancellor during covid
and so people can trust that when I say
I'm going to do something I am going to
do it the PM ask in the public to judge
him on results but when they will come
more hazy in all of these things like
you know I've deliberately not put a
specific month on on each of them
because I don't think that's responsible
or or the right thing to do with with
goals that are so complicated where many
of the forces that will impact our
ability to hit them are out of my
control as well but labor insists in
this has all been in the Tories control
and they've let the country down the big
problems that we're facing right now in
our NHS in our criminal justice system
in education they come to down to the
feelings of that conservative government
over those last 13 years and the reality
of everyday life still hard the growth
Target is going to be very challenging
it looks as though we are clearly
heading towards a recession the economic
backdrop is challenging with the
pressures from the cost of living and
the potential for unemployment to rise I
think that the inflation Target looks
reasonable we are looking at Price
levels Cooling
prime minister only promising what he
knows he can deliver but with the Tories
now 20 points behind labor in the polls
the obvious question is whether what Mr
sunak offered will be any way near
enough Beth Rigby Sky News